Psalm 91
he who dwells in the shelter of the most
high will abide in the shadow of the
Almighty
I will say to the Lord my refuge and my
Fortress my God in whom I trust
for he will deliver You From The Snare
of the Fowler and from the deadly
pestilence
he will cover you with his opinions and
under his wings you will find Refuge his
faithfulness is a shield and Buckler
you will not fear the terror of night
nor the arrow that flies by day nor the
pestilence that stalks in the darkness
now the destruction that wastes at
Noonday
a thousand may fall at your side
ten thousand at your right hand
but it will not come near you will only
look with your eyes and see the
recompense of the wicked because you
have made the Lord your Dwelling Place
the most high with my refuge
no evil shall be allowed to be for you
no play come near your tent
for he will command his angels
concerning you to guard you in all your
ways
on their hands they will bear you up
lest you strike your foot against the
stone you will Tread On The Lion and the
other the Young Lion and the serpent you
will trample Under Foot because he holds
fast to me in love
I will deliver him I will protect him
because he knows my name
when he calls to me I will answer him I
will be with him in trouble
I will rescue him and honor him
with long life I will satisfy him and
show him my salvation